mobile task forces they are the elite
special forces units of the scp
foundation whenever a particularly
dangerous anomaly rears its ugly head
you can guarantee that these members of
personnel with highly specialized skill
sets will be sent in to take care of
business a lot of the time mtfs are
relocated between different foundation
facilities or sent from location to
location hence the mobile part of the
name they vary in size and function too
with some teams being small covert
investigators and intelligence gatherers
meanwhile others might be huge
battalions consisting of hundreds of
troops vehicles and enough heavy-duty
firepower to put the terminator to shame
whether it's containing a newly emerged
scp or helping the foundation to get a
flighty anomaly back into its cage and
keeping it there the mtfs are who you're
going to call when it all hits the fan
they are the best of the scp
foundation's best and few represent that
better than mtf tau5 if you're at all
familiar with the scp foundation then
there's a good chance you've heard of
the iconic mobile task force tau5 also
known by their collective code name
samsara take everything you know about
an average task force give them leagues
better equipment and training and put
them on anomalous super steroids and
you're still likely to get an mtf who
can only dream of getting on samsara's
level in our series on the infamous site
13 you've only seen these badasses take
on horrors beyond description and not
even blink even rescuing other mobile
task forces from the jaws of death on
many occasions why are they given such
prestige even in a crowded field of
elite foundation operatives it's because
the four members of the samsara team are
unlike any other mtfs on a fundamental
level given that each one of them was
created from the flesh of a dead god
sounds cool enough on its own right well
not only are tau-5 specially created
from a divine deity but each of them has
also had their bodies enhanced with
cutting-edge cybernetics these immortal
cyborgs can be upgraded at any time as
and when the need arises using the
latest of the foundation's experimental
weaponry to combat and contain all kinds
of anomalous threats from the
thamaturgic and psionic to even powerful
reality warping entities that a normal
mtf couldn't dream of handling together
samsara consists of two male operatives
named irantu and munro and two females
nanku and onru and that's all you need
to know before we delve into the
insanity that comes next buckle up and
put on your scramble goggles it's time
for avatara long ago there was a deity
known as the lord of endowments a god
who once assumed the persona of
prometheus no not the terrible ridley
scott movie prometheus was a figure from
ancient greek mythology who stole the
gift of knowledge from the gods of mount
olympus and gifted it to the people of
earth often represented as metaphorical
fire as punishment for his transgression
prometheus was chained to the side of a
mountain where every day he would have
his liver pecked out by birds only for
it to grow back overnight so the birds
could feed on him again the next day
so our lord of endowment stopped
giggling you at the back gave himself a
body of flesh so that he might walk upon
the earth as a giant humanoid his goal
was to like prometheus provide mankind
with knowledge and power to grant them
technology and then redefine what it
meant to be human the lord amassed
followers as a result and began to
conquer new territories to expand his
power however something changed and the
lord gradually began to die whether it
was the result of him becoming flesh and
therefore mortal a betrayal by his
armies of followers or punishment from
the other gods for his exploits the lord
of endowment decided to split his mortal
form into three parts in order to
survive these were his mind body and
spirit and they were hidden across the
earth with his body being buried deep
within the tabernace desert in spain
where his mind also slept with his body
jump forward several thousand years in a
group known as prometheus labs
discovered the dormant flesh body of the
lord of endowment prometheus labs was
once a group of interests to the scp
foundation known for researching
anomalous objects with the goal of using
them to develop new technological
breakthroughs unearthing the lord's body
the prometheus scientists discovered
that the body's liver contained cells
that could endlessly regenerate
eventually harvesting and researching
these cells resulted in a brand new
research project the goal to create a
group of a mortal warriors prometheus
labs took four volunteers and uploaded
their consciousnesses to a computer
hoping to then download them into new
bodies that were cloned from the
regenerating cells the thought was if
one of these cloned bodies was destroyed
or somehow became so badly damaged that
it couldn't be used then this process
could be used to upload the same mind to
a fresh body as simple as booting up a
new computer with an old hard drive the
project did produce some results seeing
the creation of some mass-produced
cyborg warriors later known as scp-1637
however the research was cut short when
a surviving group of the lord of
endowments followers stormed prometheus
labs the followers raided the entire
facility shooting the newly cloned
bodies that were intended to be the
hosts for the four consciousnesses that
had been saved to the computer but even
those were destroyed along with all the
backup drives that contained copies of
the four minds the lord's followers
destroyed the prometheus facility but
the machine used to create the clones
miraculously survived it began gradually
creating four new bodies despite
sustaining heavy damage the problem was
the minds and bodies of the four
volunteers were all gone their lives
thoughts emotions imagination
everything their humanity had been
stored on the hard drive that the
followers had destroyed but still the
machine did what machines do it cloned
four new bodies but there was nothing to
inhabit them nothing more than a simple
template two genders and four names
years go by and prometheus labs suffered
another major accident which eventually
led to the organization disbanding
however some of the former scientists
were scooped up by the scp foundation
including one doctor who had survived
the attack at the cloning facility he
took a group of the foundation's agents
to the location of that old project
where they found four almost featureless
fleshy shells empty but ready to be
transformed into an asset the likes of
which the foundation had never possessed
before the prometheus labs project that
had almost been for nothing lived on
samsara more time passes until the
members of mtf tao 5 also known as
samsara were eventually sent in to deal
with a new anomaly that had started to
spread it originated from within a
seemingly ordinary farmhouse however
when anything organic entered it would
rapidly become cancerous in much the
same vein anything mechanical brought
into the house would break down this
meant that sending in any human
personnel or even unmanned drones were
options that were off the table for the
foundation so instead they called in
samsara after all if you need to send
someone into a house that causes certain
death why not four functionally immortal
cyborgs the members of mtf tau-5 were
constructed from the same basic mind
template meaning that all four of them
lacked any real humanity they react to
anomalies very casually in terms of
their emotions but respond extremely
seriously in terms of executing a task
or containing an scp
granted this makes them a formidable
fighting force but even though they try
to hide it behind acting human tau 5
have very little understanding of
emotions as they enter the house they
heard the sound of religious chanting
and began to follow it back to its
source in the bedroom samsara discovered
a figure hidden behind a tumor so big
that it appeared to just be one huge
mass of twisted flesh provide him your
flesh the creature chanted sat it's
thirst give it your flesh that he may
make you guards tau5 was given the order
to terminate the creature that seemed to
be the source of the anomaly but their
shots only ricocheted off the fleshy
mass the entity could not be killed by
anything not made from flesh irantu
ordered nanku to hand him her pistol and
didn't hesitate to shoot her multiple
times in the neck he started hacking
away at the dead nanku's neck with a
combat knife while onru and munru helped
iran to finish decapitating her taking a
grenade from nanku's belt he stuffed it
into the mouth of his teammate's severed
head pulled the pin and threw a deep
into the cancerous mass diving out of
harm's way in the last second the
remaining members of samsara took cover
as the grenade detonated killing the
anomaly and showering the room with
gooey bits of muscles intestines brain
tissue and bone marrow hope you weren't
eating while watching this one folks
they had no reservations about killing
one of their own but tau5 had
neutralized the anomaly and its effects
had stopped spreading outside the
farmhouse samsara re-entered the bedroom
only for one of them munro to discover
something among the blood guts and
viscera that remained underneath piles
of flesh stained with meat was a small
leather-bound book munru took it with
him hiding it away this tome was a
grimoire a type of ancient textbook of
magic typically a grumoire includes
instructions on how to create magical
objects talismans amulets and the like
or numbers spells and magic charms but
some grimoires also instruct a reader on
how to summon or invoke supernatural
entities calling forth beings from the
great beyond like angels spirits demons
and deities and this particular book
described how to summon the essence of a
certain promethean plunderer the lord of
endowment himself somehow the cancerous
tumor-spreading entity from the
farmhouse that affected both flesh and
technology seemed to have been created
by this book so why would one of the mtf
tau5 take the grimoire surely as a
member of samsara manru would normally
react to anomalies with the same
emotionless pragmatism he and his
teammates shared and would never think
to stash this spell book on his person
unless of course munru was being
manipulated by some force without
realizing it the mind of the lord
knowing that this book was an important
tool for his resurrection had managed to
influence munru into keeping the
grimoire the members of samsara returned
to headquarters where they all began
looking over the book over the next two
weeks nanku's head was reformed and
meticulously put back together by the
foundation left with only the scars from
all the stitching around her face head
and neck luckily for irantu the tau
fives lack the emotional capacity to
hold grudges after all think about it
how would you feel if your co-worker
decided to behead you and use your
severed head as a bomb sounds like quite
the headache god i make terrible jokes
as the tau5 team studied the book they
found themselves enjoying it learning
about a place where they could learn
more about acting like people a place
they then hoped to visit perhaps because
it was the place they'd first started if
you were paying attention earlier in
this video you'll remember we told you
the mtf tau5 members were created from
the flesh of a dead god and this
particular dead god buried his body in
the tabernace desert in spain it was
none other than the lord of endowment
that had been used to create the four
immortal cyborgs of mtf tau five the
samsara team had come from him and now
he was trying to tempt them back now go
check out scp elite mobile task force
explained and scp-1730 what happened to
site 13 the full story compilation for
more of samsara and the other teams they
work with